express my gratitude to the organizer
Sarah and Andrew
this particular topic is quite
interesting for me we are talking about
States and borders and we have very
strange interesting panel here we have
uh solved mullard then can bore than
William sacks and then we have Professor
gun sidel love
so uh next one and a half hours we will
be now talking about this very important
topic
before I give the floor to the panelists
and then the respondents I would like to
spend few minutes to express in terms of
what is the situation in terms of the
states and borders in the Hindu
kushimalan region if you look
into the connections in the past and now
ecosystems custom services and cultures
they are the ones which has connected uh
the
people and the natural systems upstreams
downstreams in the Hindu shamalan region
that region but what has been the
problem is the conflict
and the conflict has come because of the
states and borders and the conflict has
been there for centuries and if you look
into the history this is one of the hot
spots of conflict so this is another
Paradigm that IVC we have connections we
have the conflict situation
one good example of one
cultural connection which existed till
very recently is a good point to remind
how the cultural connection was there
the religious connection I think most of
you know
in tibetan which is called kailas
this particular area is almost 1000
kilometer away from Bhutan and Bhutan
was actually collecting Revenue until
few decades ago so you can imagine how
culturally they were Linked In Spite of
so much of distance and there was such a
excellent cooperation taking place
now uh as the time passed I think the
conflicts also became quite evident and
recently you see many conflicts uh in
the last 40 50 years in that region and
establishment of easy mode itself is a
good example where you can see there is
a good will as well as a
intention for cooperation 30 years ago
there was an intergovernmental Charter
signed by eight countries to start
working at least at the technical level
uh by the establishment of this
institute
but there were difficulties and
challenges that this institute also felt
because of the borders and the states
they have their own interest but I can
tell you one example or the recent
development after 2007 ipcc report which
came
there was a controversy of Glacier
melting
it said that by 2035 all glaciers will
melt all of a sudden the reactions from
these countries were so much positive
for working in a regional context
more ownership has increased and we see
there is a regional approach emerging in
the countries countries like China and
India in 2008 they came up with national
report on climate change and clearly
both the countries have shown interest
to work with their neighbors India has a
specific mission on Himalayan sustaining
Himalayan ecosystem and it talks about
they have to work with their borders so
there is a very clear intention coming
also see the climate change report of
2008 from China there is a similar
intention so there is a clear
understanding that is emerging that the
Himalayan region has to be actually
managed by cooperation not by their own
individual Identity or this stage I
think this is one big message that I
would like to give and two examples
how you see one is intention another one
is operationalization there had been
intention all the time but now I see
there is operationalization also taking
place take example of recent work that
we have started to work is in kailash
China India and Nepal cooperating and
India very clearly is projecting that
they are able to Pilot what they have
said in national uh action plan for
climate change by working with China and
Nepal in kerala's landscape so that is
the type of attitudinal change that we
are seeing in case of china The
Institute of mountain Hazard and
Institute of octavital plateau research
they came up with a very Innovative idea
of starting a work in kosi
River Basin where substantial parties in
China Nepal and the downstream India and
now through isimos initiative all three
countries are cooperating in a big
program so what I would like to give a
message here when we talk about the
states and the borders
there had been challenges there had been
opportunities but because of climate
change and recent development we see
there are interests of cooperating not
just in terms of a very high strategic
level discussion but at the operational
level also we are seeing cooperation
happening happening there are many
examples of such uh cooperation emerging
in the region with this comment now I
would like to invite the first panelist
Dr Sol Muller
for your presentation
thank you
um
firstly I've like to thank the
organizers of this Workshop uh it's
necessary at times I suppose to rethink
some of the ideas and assumptions within
our field and reflect upon our combined
knowledge of the Himalaya it's an honor
and a privilege to be a part of this
process
a few years ago uh Sarah and I we met in
Cambridge and we discussed
um
states borders and territoriality and
it seems fitting to sort of continue
those discussions within this panel
framework
so
um
States and borders well
the impact of states
and the formation of borders of course
change over time and we've had today uh
over the last couple of days the
discussion of uh
both States and boundaries
but mostly in the context of
contemporary times
so
I suppose my issues with the questions
that have been framed for this panel is
really
what do we mean historically by
boundaries and states
that is
when I read these questions
um
the language
sort of naturally leads me to think
about the Contemporary period and
interactions between nation states
and and communities
and perhaps that's because of the
importance of states and borders and
that it's uh I suppose primarily an
issue of the present
how borders and states are understood
ultimately derives from the meanings we
give them
and the time period in which we believe
them to be important
for example James Scott last night said
borders are usually seen as an obstacle
whereas they can actually be regions of
opportunity
as a historian I understand the
underlying idea behind that statement
that territorial boundaries are modern
interaction in place that is now bounded
is old
I'm not sure whether
uh what I'm about to say is a case of
flogging a dead dog or stating the
obvious or challenging assumptions but
um let's let's get on with it um anyway
I'd like to preface what I'm about to
say with the number of caveats of course
the Himalaya is a complicated region and
whatever may be true in one Valley or
Community can often be contradicted by
research findings of another community
of value
in this presentation I'll be mainly
making use of examples from my own area
of research which is sikim and the
second Muse Himalaya
so I want to touch upon a few issues
related to the questions uh frame for
this panel how do we understand States
and boundaries in the Himalaya and is
there value in considering a
trans-regional uh Himalaya versus the
nation or Community perhaps as a unit of
analysis
so how do we understand States and
boundaries in the Himalayan assumption
that is often prevalent in
uh certain forms of History I suppose of
various States and the Himalaya to a
certain extent
um
is that polities are defined by borders
perhaps this is because the development
in the post-war period of the
international idea of the bounded
Sovereign nation-state and the ideal of
such States is so dominant in our minds
but because we understand states by and
large according to
perhaps Weber's bounded definition
we often persist in bounded Politics as
in abounded political entity as a unit
of historical analysis that's to say
there are many books on the political
history of Nepal Bhutan and Tibet and
now thanks to my own preoccupation with
States at least one book on Sikkim yet
few
um on The Wider perhaps political themes
in the Himalaya
or looking at the Himalaya in terms of a
regional history
um that would be fine
um to use the states as a natural
bounded entity as a unit of analysis if
I suppose we were consistent in the use
of the term of the stage we often use it
to mean a political core a center or a
government a political or legal
organizational structure
and we often use it when we mean a
system of Taxation
in essence
we use it to mean different things the
term itself is not adequately defined
and one thing that has concerned my own
work I suppose is the question should we
be thinking of states in the Himalaya by
their bounded territory or lack thereof
or by their functions for as Charles
Tilley noted
states do not come about because of the
desire to build a state and form
boundaries but instead by the wish of a
ruler to increase his own wealth and
power
with that in mind is it necessary for
the political entities in the Himalaya
to be territorially bound and if not
does this mean that they are not states
of course this question has been in part
answered by the application of the
galactic quality model whereby control
diminishes the further one gets away
from a political core and related
literature
um
so while states in the Himalaya at least
in the pre-modern period certainly which
shared those characteristics I'm not 100
convinced convinced that this uh model
clearly covers all our understandings of
territorial space as conceived by the
states
whatever we mean by the term the state
that is even though the political
reality May indicate political cause and
weak or fluid boundaries according to
the Western view of what a boundary is
the idea of bounded space does in fact
resonate with the people of the Himalaya
people in the Himalaya do understand
land and space often in bounded terms
Charles mentioned last night there
exists extensive written records on
Boundary creation and Boundary
maintenance of course such material as
James got also noted last night may have
been constructed because there was
actually the problem of people escaping
State control but more relevant to my
work is Charles's idea of inner and out
space whereby people clearly understand
space and territory and bounded terms or
my own work on political Authority super
imposed upon sacred boundaries are in
the hidden land
both examples have shown that they're
really aren't that there are indigenous
ideas of bounded space in some cases the
idea then of bounded space is very
clearly defined as geographical features
limited space as in the case with
irrigated Fields limited by Shale
covered valleys dust Gorges Cliffs or
non-cult cultivatable land more
generally or in Sikkim where territorial
space was bounded by dense jungles
surrounding human settlements
so sometimes when the boundaries are
very clearly defined on the basis of
cultivate sometimes then the boundaries
are then very clearly defined on the
basis of cultivatable use
territories on the other hand however
is not always understood in terms of
such clear features of demarcation
instead I think the territory at least
as far as the secondary state was
concerned is the linking in connection
of such territorial enclaves some of
which
would you graphically located within
Bhutan and Tibet
that is territory is not understood as
being necessarily A contiguous space
including all land irrespective of its
usage
for example in sikhemy's tax records we
do not find larger geographical
definitions of territories within
Estates rather we find references to the
enclaves of the human settlements
and it is perhaps assumed that these are
defined and delimited by the
geographical obstacles that surround
them of course and there's a caveat to
that we we don't want to become
geographically deterministic and we're
aware of the geographic studies that
have shown that these so-called natural
boundaries do not limit interaction but
actually in most cases facilitate it
lakes rivers and seas unite not divide
for example
and we also know from our own field that
the Himalayan Mountains have not
hindered or prevented the interaction of
people in ideas
but in terms of State understanding of
territory the place of settlement and
the cultivatable fields associated with
it is a very important unit of the
analysis as it's the state's ultimate
economic base
um
yeah
um so
historically speaking
banded space or spounded territorial
spaces perhaps best understood at least
in the sikhemy's context in terms of
usage and meaning it's not passive it's
not simply a place or a location within
which Human Action takes place instead
it's a product of a dynamic process of
the organization and layout of land a
process produced out of different
meanings and practices and into
relationships involving human
communities institutions and struggles
to find and control resources or ideas
so
um
so due to this geographical places or
regions perhaps can become mistaken as
being Unbound fluid
when in fact
places a subject perhaps to more
multiple projections of bounded Space by
different people communities and
institutions that is
land is understood by the people who use
it
um a polity like early Sikkim then
understands perhaps territorial space in
terms of its relationship to it I.E
primarily as a source of Revenue thus
territory for the sikhimis Kings becomes
bounded by the fact that there is a
geographical location where the
collection of taxes stop and not by
political control over the place where
tax collection stops
of course
the people who reside in those
geographical locations where the taxes
stop uh say for example Ilan Darjeeling
and North Bengal Plains in the second
East context
had obviously a completely different
understanding of the place where they
reside
and their production of territorial
space is understood and constructed
differently
the payment to taxes in Sikkim does not
for them necessarily represent the
territorial possession of their space
bias again in fact it represents an act
of keeping tsikami's polity perhaps at
Bay as we find a number of Taxation
records in which these regions are
paying taxes for the British the Gorka
and the sycamese
but the resulting fact is that I suppose
three states then believe that those
regions form part of their territory
when clearly the opposite was true
so turning to the sort of question of
bout
political histories for understanding
uh
dynamics of change
one of the
uh
social political histories I think to
emerge in recent years has been the book
by Bernardo Michaels has just come out
this year State making and territory in
South Asia lessons from the Anglo Gorka
War instead of focusing on the political
core of a state or Interstate Foreign
Relations he looks at both the Gorka and
the British States from the vantage
point of the communities and political
entities on the frontier
the regions of the tarai like the
examples of East Nepal North Bengal and
the Sikkim Frontier Michael shows also
used their confused territorial identity
in terms of Western concepts of
territory defined by boundaries was
aware of evading the larger states of
British Bengal and gork and Nepal
and it was only after the anglo-gorca
war that the British attempted to
demarcate the order of Bengal on the
ball and that this border became
formalized into the existence through
the production of space and territory by
the British through cartography
however this production of state-defined
territory as opposed did little to deal
with the underlying tensions that these
projections caused
there continue to be the existence of an
indigenous territorial president
straddling the border the British
thought to delimit
I suppose a problem that really
continues in the current medeshi
movement in in Nepal in some ways
so
then on a sort of State Historical level
I suppose there is a difference of
understanding borders and Boundary
bounded space
um
you know the idea of a static line
um as we all know versus you know
indigenous understandings of space
um
and uh
which you know ultimately rested not on
the dominating control of the people and
territory up to specific geographical
line but instead upon a place where the
state can exercise its principal
function the collection of Revenue
um I suppose the lesson learned from
these examples is that if we view
bounded space
uh
you know
in terms of the idea of the Border
rather than in terms of multiple
indigenous meanings and the usage of
space that straddle contemporary borders
uh you know we fall into the same trap
the British fell into and this says
ramifications for how we understand
States and borders in the Himalaya and
raises issues regarding States as a unit
of analysis
so is there a value in considering a
trans Himalayan region versus the nation
or state as a unit of analysis
I suppose the answer depends upon what
one is studying ultimately and answers
to these questions change dramatically
if one focuses on
and I'm doing okay for time okay I'm
trying to
tie it back into the questions
um that are framed
um so I suppose the idea depends upon
what is and one may be studying answers
to this question changely changes
dramatically if one focuses on I don't
know medieval period the pre-modern up
until the mid 20th century the modern or
the Contemporary Himalaya
uh so in more recent times however the
state can be quite a useful unit for
understanding change in society and the
perceived idea of shared National
History or the production thereof
for example
uh
in Nepal from the 1950s you know one
thinks about Nepalese nationalism
and how it was defined by Elites and
promoted through education in terms of
uh history Nepali Language and Hinduism
an indication that despite the fact that
you know in 1963 the structural
inequality enshrined you know within the
Malachi Ein
um and the hierarchic classification of
cast and Community was legally abolished
the ideas and
inequalities that are inherent within
that system still persisted so on the
one hand an understanding of the
political history of the state which
created this structure of hierarchy as
vital to understanding concurrent
movements for ethnic recognition within
Nepal
on the other hand However the fact that
similar issues of ethnic identity have
key ingredients within Indian national
and Indian Himalayan political uh
politics suggests that a regional view
is also relevant
so
you know in that particular example are
we are we looking at a case of
trans-regional ethnicism you know the
construction of ethnic identity
in Sikkim
um you know the creation of ethnicism
like uh uh in Nepal is also understood
historically resulting from the
settlement of Nepali laborers by the
first British political office of Sikkim
but today the creation of ethnic
identity is framed within the Indian
national Dialogue on Carson tribal
reservation quotas
so
I don't know where this takes us in
terms of the state versus the
trans-regional
um
unit
so perhaps I'll end by sort of saying
that whilst
uh ethnicist constructions across across
the Himalaya indicate a certain
trajectory of thought which transcends
national boundaries tsukumi's ethnicists
explorations of ethnic Discovery in
Nepal for example and the shared the
sharing of political strategies across
International boundary boundaries
so the political struggles for
recognition ultimately take place in the
arena of the nation-state yet although
these take place in the National context
of India and Nepal these movements if
one takes the modesty movement into
account are also geographically speaking
trans Himalayan interactions
they're just in a direction we do not
normally consider as being trans
anything because they're happening
within the so-called boundaries of the
nation state
um
so
I will stop there
all right uh we have a tough job because
we're preventing you from lunch right
and some of you from leaving and so bear
with us and thank you for your patience
thank you for having us Sarah and Andrew
and it's it's as I'll Echo Saul's note
that it's a privilege and and a real
kind of pleasure to be here amongst lots
of old friends and new friends
um and uh and Saul had a couple of
things that I think I can use quite
easily to segue into my comments and
we've heard the last uh day or so a lot
about uh wrestling with this question of
what are the Himalayas or where are the
Himalayas I'm looking at Dave and I'm
thinking David and I'm thinking you know
with your Maps you showed us or gave us
some ideas on what you know where are
the Himalayas or way ways that we can
conceptualize this thing and and
um we've heard uh some discussions of uh
let's you know what are the Himalayas in
terms of identity or uh everyday
religions Etc so I'm going to suggest
maybe a different rubric or way of
thinking about it I'm going to say that
um first of all
um
when are the Himalayas okay and this is
I think part of what what Saul is
suggesting is is our Notions of of what
the Himalayas are are are are actually
very time dependent um and I'm going to
make an argument that the a real
watershed moment in terms of what the
Himalayas are did occur in this this
this post-independence uh uh you know 19
late 1940s to 1960s period um and that
uh there were some fundamental changes
that happened in terms of of of what the
Himalayas were and what they became
um and then the other thing I'm going to
also say is rather than what or where
are the Himalayas I'm going to say uh
what four are the Himalayas okay so who
is mobilizing uh the Himalayas and for
what purposes um and I think that that
also will tell us a lot about what what
the Himalayas are if we look at
um who and and why are they are are we
mobilizing this concept of the Himalayas
so
um that's a some rough kind of uh
framing remarks um I enjoyed cats uh
talk yesterday I guess she's not here
anymore but in terms of a disciplinary
history of anthropology and it's
appropriate I think for us also to
introduce ourselves in that respect so I
entered into Nepal in a certain moment
in the 1990s when uh we could never
think of I'll say for myself I could
never think of Nepal without thinking
about the state okay I enter I learned
Nepali when uh the the spring after the
Democratic movement okay
um I entered Kathmandu uh in the era of
big development money I entered uh Nepal
during the pollution era
um so none of these ideas about the
Himalayas at least for I I can I think I
can speak for my cohort uh were
considered
um uh somehow that Himalayas were
separate from a relationship with the
state or with non-state agents as well
um and so uh you know we never thought
of the Himalayas I think as Timeless or
isolated or or any of these other kinds
of tropes that were perhaps perpetuated
for a long time so again when the Hima
the Himalayas so for me when is the
1990s and and that certainly has a
certain um uh respect on what I chose to
study then and um the ways that I
represented the Himalayas
um
and also not to mention the maoist era
was certainly an important uh kind of
historical moment that we entered into
Nepal with
um
all right um
I want to also suggest uh that
um
uh in the pre-1960 era particularly in
the Border regions that I've spent a lot
of time in uh um one perhaps heuristic
device that we can use also to
understand the Himalayas are niches okay
and that I think that fundamentally uh
um the niche that was occupied by
various Himalayan communities or groups
over time had a very important impact on
what they then became in terms of
Himalayan communities and one example I
can you know easily give from my own
research is is the area in Western Nepal
of dolpo where through let's say the mid
1990s it was isolated uh marginal quite
poor and didn't figure on the national
imaginary whatsoever in in Nepal a
couple of events happened then
an Academy Award nominated film gets
made there but more importantly
yatsugumbu suddenly Dawn's on the scene
on the Tibetan plateau and uh so what
was once a backward marginal area is
suddenly very much at one of the
important centers of uh trade for this
incredibly valuable commodity um so uh
the niche that dolpo occupied the fact
that Yazoo goombu it can be found there
or in a new word uh um some of these
other valleys is very important likewise
uh without Mount Everest the niche that
the Sherpas occupy you can't imagine
what um that part of the Himalayas would
be like right
um uh I don't know and and
um I don't think we know sufficiently
about uh the processes of of State
incorporation and state formation over
time in the Himalayas I mean I I take a
lot of guidance from Charles and his his
his textual analysis of uh the and
social history of this this uh these
economic spheres interacting so tax
records and
Boundary making exercises and these
kinds of things but we know very very
little about actually how it happened I
mean turning today told us that uh you
know millions of pounds of or kilos of
dung were required to run a monastery so
likewise I mean do we really know much
about how these states were these many
states city-states as we've heard um
actually were governed uh and as a small
example of that um for my PhD project in
in the tar uh I gathered um using a
historical document over 1300 place
names 500 of which I got GPS points for
and could write just a boundary of this
of boundaries of the Pastors in this
area right but the other document that I
didn't have was the taxation document
that linked those units with how many
sheep were actually there at any given
moment right so even as I got a very
close-up look at how carefully a place
was uh the boundaries were created I
don't even know what happened inside
those boundaries right so I think we we
don't know a lot about how these places
were governed how the Himalayas were
governed at multiple levels
that being said
um uh I'll still assert that um uh the
processes of State incorporation and
state making were qualitatively
different at uh prior to the 1950s and
60s than they were after that and that a
lot of what we look at today in terms of
the Himalayan region um are are in
Dynamic with estate making and state
incorporation by the States of China
India Nepal Etc
um
okay
in phase two what I'll call the phase
two uh the post 1960s period won the
Border uh across the Himalayas was
closed there was a lot of tension
obviously conflicts that we've heard
about
um uh effectively a border was that was
once
quite free-flowing or porous became
hardened and um uh you know that that I
it's it's to make the point that borders
really did matter thereafter and they
continue to matter
um
and another example just I'm I'm trying
also to bring in various talks or points
that have been made over the last day or
so
um I also want to make the point um with
respect to collaboration that borders
really matter right so if we work with a
Nepali versus working with a Tibetan uh
um the kind information that we can
access and the kind of ways that we
represent the Himalayas are very
determined by national borders then
right who we work with and I think most
of us are are now working very actively
with collaborators
um so now
um uh I don't want to rehearse the the
the whole history of of the post 1960s
period for any given region I think we
have pretty good coverage and Bo and I
were talking about this we have some
pretty good coverage for the Nepal
Himalaya what happened in these uh
various Himalayan communities when the
Border uh as I said was hardened or or
that became more of uh
um a place that was incorporated into
the state
um uh but
um you know what what about if going
beyond that can we still think about the
Himalayas as a unit of analysis if we um
are at least on this panel um asserting
that that borders make a very important
uh impression or um uh difference in
terms of how we view the Himalayas how
can we use that the Himalayas as a unit
of analysis that's still interesting or
useful or productive a couple of things
that I would want to say on that one is
methodological I think
um uh that uh the region of the
Himalayas if we're dealing with
something like climate change it is a
useful Regional unit of analysis and uh
and as you're suggesting isamod is
trying to approach it operationalize it
in in a regional way
um I think pedagogically here we are at
a university I think pedagogically the
Himalayas are an interesting way to
organize information and to think about
patterns in new ways that are outside of
national borders so that we can think
about new ways of understanding uh
economies or understanding Terror Tories
or understanding
you know artistic lineages Etc right so
it can be a useful um unit of analysis I
think there
I also think that um you know I want to
get now to the point where I'm talking a
little bit about
um what are the Himalayas for how are
they used or how are they mobilized how
are they produced one thing is that I
should I think again to honor Jim Scott
I think there are a lot of hidden
transcripts about
um uh the Himalayas that a lot of dark
Corners to use settings analogy that we
really don't know about and so uh um we
should be careful to about our claims
are humble about our claims about what
we know about the Himalayas just because
there are so many hidden transcripts
um uh I think the Himalayas is also used
as an environment it's a produced
environment and I'll give you an example
yesterday we talked a lot about the
environmental degradation Theory the
Himalayan environmental degradation
Theory and
the the feeling that you got in the room
was that well that's kind of passe or
it's past tense and we're no longer
really uh ensnared by these um sort of
discourses but I think uh you just need
to go north of the Border in the
Himalayas and rangeland degradation
discourse is alive and well uh and it is
um it is producing uh an environment uh
in this case the the Tibetan rangeland
environment that is
um uh being degraded and mismanaged and
uh in the in the incapable hands of of
uh uh let's say
primitive subsistence
Nomads and
um I would also say that you know
efforts like isamod in some senses
produce Himalayan environments that that
are
strategic in the sense of uh they
certainly leverage sources of funding
um ideas about the Himalaya Etc so uh
and that's definitely the case in the
rangelands in China where this discourse
is strategically instrumentally used and
leveraged to attract funding sources and
ways of representing those environment
that may not really be
reflecting any objective ecological or
cultural or social reality
um
I also think the Himalayas have been
produced as a development project or as
a development entity
um uh isamata is but one example of that
but uh it would be interesting to think
about how uh people's living in the
Himalayas have been produced as
Himalayan subjects particularly under
this the the Aegis of development
projects and I think of one example
um uh because I was trying to think of
of are there examples where where local
populations mobilize or use this term of
the Himalaya right as an identifier and
the only one I can think of and Charles
is very familiar with this example is
the Himalayan omshi Association
um and I can think of very few other
you know entities that use Himalaya in
their title um and certainly not bote uh
in their title um I'll speak for the you
know the Nepal case but
um why is it that the OMG Association
calls itself the Himalayan omshi
Association
um well it it's uh it's non-tibetan then
um and that avoids the political
sensitivities uh it is um a regional
thing and therefore they get to
represent themselves as
um uh as a non-political and across the
transnational they can pick up people
from uh you know from Sikkim to Bhutan
to uh um Nepal Etc uh but that's really
the only example I could think of where
where the Himalayas are are
mobilized uh in the name of an
organization
um a new one though a good friend of
many people in this room tenza Norbu a
well-known painter from from dolpo uh
his latest idea is actually to create a
Himalayan culture center but where is he
creating it or wants to create it in
Kathmandu and so so the other thing that
I really want to emphasize and from my
take is that I think the Himalayas if
you want to see where they are uh or or
where they are produced it's in the
urban centers and we saw plenty of
evidence of that with respect to you
know Jeff showing us all the Facebook
pages and things like this ideas about
the Himalayas are being produced in in
urban centers and people
um you know those kids who go to school
in Kathmandu and think of themselves
later on as belonging to Himalayan areas
it's also in part because they're all
mixing into places like Kathmandu right
if a person from dolpo never knew a
person from olongjongola before the
1960s they just you know it was but now
there is a much broader I would say kind
of uh pan Himalayan sense of we are
mountain peoples uh perhaps they'll call
them botes themselves bote perhaps not
um but again I think Urban centers are
an important place to actually look for
the Himalayas ironically
um
and uh finally um I also want to uh sort
of my last metaphor or kind of heuristic
device is thinking about the Himalayas
as a lived experience and I just
completed a set of interviews with old
Traders from dolpo people who had
um you know spent 40 years going back
and forth across this border
um uh and you know resurrected their
trade after the Border was opened up
again and
um I hired uh actually tens of norbu's
son so the third generation of a dolpo
person I hired him to help me carry out
these interviews and what was so
striking about those interviews is that
two people uh from dolpo uh talking
about dolpo but the one man had has a
lived experience okay you know he had he
would describe how long the passes are
that they had to you know he said oh
it's almost like it was like climbing up
to the sky it was so high and so hard
and we worked so hard and it was
suffering um and then this generation
their lived experience of the Himalayas
is is is as I've said an urban one
um is one that is uh also wrapped up in
all kinds of new modes and Technologies
of representation
um but it may not necessarily be uh um
as much of a lived experience and how
does that then affect you know what we
call the Himalayas um I'll stop there
um okay the light is Dawning at the end
of the tunnel
last paper last day if you if you can
stay awake till the end of this one then
you all get to have lunch and then
continue our conversation but um
thanks uh to Sarah and Andy and uh and
the organizers for the conference for
having me here it's nice to meet some
new people
um
yeah
last year I had the occasion to think
about a pan Himalayan project with some
Partners from India and Europe we had
developed what I thought was quite a an
excellent project which is probably why
it was rejected by the European funders
but as we discussed the project we the
question arose whether Himalayan studies
is really possible
and a lot of people would say that it is
not
before I proceed to summarize some of
the better known critiques of area
studies I should say that I personally
am deeply committed to area studies
that's why I moved to Germany something
I had never in my wildest dreams thought
that I would do I moved there to join
the south Asia Institute because I am so
interested in the region so I am
committed to it but there are these
critiques of it and the critiques are
important for us to think about if we're
thinking about area studies and how to
do it William Van schendel for example
has argued that area studies are best
understood as artifacts of Cold War
politics
and when you look at how they were
defined
in the nineteen
sixties uh now how are we going to do
this
yeah
and when you look at they were how they
were defined in the 1960s
how can I go full screen here
right when you look at the how they were
defined in the 60s and 70s it's hard to
argue with him
but to Define area studies in such a
crude way it obscures as much as it
reveals it makes me think of a recent
book which I would highly recommend
called Asian medicine and globalization
and the introduction to this book by
Joseph alter makes the same point it
shows convincingly How Deeply the frame
of the nation state has distorted our
discourse in this case the idea that
ayurveda is Indian medicine and TCM is
Chinese medicine even though we know
this isn't true we don't realize how
deeply the frame influences our thinking
and this conference has Illustrated the
point with particular Clarity our topic
was supposedly the Himalayas but nearly
everyone talked to either about Nepal or
Tibet uh I challenged this on the first
day but clearly it didn't really make
anyone rethink about their presentation
by my count some 80 percent of the
presentations were not about the
Himalayas but about aspects of Tibet uh
or Nepal thus perfectly exemplifying the
standard critique of area studies which
is either that it reifies the
nation-state which would be Nepal or
that it hermetically isolates itself in
a kind of exceptionalism that is Tibetan
studies
in fact Himalayan studies per se if
there were such a thing would escape
this critique since it would have to be
transnational and transcultural by
definition
there's a second important critique of
area studies which is that it makes
little sense to speak of South Asian
culture or Indian culture or Tibetan
culture
this critique is very pronounced right
now in my intellectual World in
Heidelberg where we have a very large
interdisciplinary research project
devoted to transcultural studies
transcultural studies does not Define
culture as something primordial which
belongs to ethnically or regionally
defined groups but rather as something
that is always emergent cultures are
ever in a process of becoming they
consist of nothing other than extensive
borrowings and transformations of
exogenous elements the agenda of
transcultural studies is to reframe the
idea of culture so that we no longer
associate it with political units or
particular regions or ethnic groups
therefore this approach questions the
holistic approach to culture favored
like anthropologists like me
who tend to regard a culture's language
kinship system and religion and so forth
as more or less integrated
now there are at least two things to say
about this approach first of all this is
nothing new
cultural anthropologists have been
making similar points for quite some
time now
second nothing increases demand better
than sexy advertising
repackaging these old ideas as
transcultural studies has given
Heidelberg nearly 20 million euros in
funding and a large portion has gone to
Himalayan studies including a new
professor the introduction of Tibetan to
the dozen or so South Asian languages we
teach
but the main point I wish to make is
just that Himalayan studies if it really
existed would Escape both of these
critiques since um
they are not defined by any particular
nation state or any particular culture
so if Himalayan studies cannot be
defined in terms of politics States or
particular cultures then how should we
Define it to this question there is a
short answer a medium answer and a long
answer
the short answer is painfully obvious
it's the geography stupid
the Himalayas are a chain of mountains
like Polynesia or melanesia they are
geographically distinctive and they
require a real cultural geography that
means uh
interdisciplinary work by historians
geographers and anthropologists uh I'm
talking about what Boaz called culture
history
um the medium long medium answer Builds
on what Chris the son Kumar said
yesterday
he asked if we wanted to stay with the
blunt physicality of the mountains and
of course we don't want to stay there
for one thing we will never be able to
precisely delimit the Himalayas how we
Define them will always depend on the
questions that we ask if we ask about
movements and connections as Chris did
or if we ask about representations of
the Himalayas as we did this morning
then our definition will immediately go
far beyond the mountains themselves
but the question of where to start
Himalayan studies the question of how to
conceptualize area studies is a
pragmatic question involving funding
institutions curricula and so forth and
for these purposes I do believe that we
should start with the obvious that the
Himalayas are a mountain chain and that
the best way to study them is boazian
cultural history which in fact includes
a lot of geography
what about the long answer
here I would begin by noting that with
respect to area studies David Ludden has
very sensibly written that quote there
is no theory of area studies or of
area-specific knowledge there is only a
set of institutional personal and
fragmented disciplinary market and
professional interests that converge
primarily on funding
close quote
as someone who is deeply committed to
area studies I take ludden's comments as
a worthwhile challenge
uh last year in a major speech I tried
to make a tentative contribution to a
theory of area studies based on the
theoretical principle of context the
ontological principle of practice and
the methodological principle of scale
but I'm going to spare you that today
and just summarize it and say my basic
point is that every question has an
appropriate scale and that the scale is
decisive in determining the methods that
you use to answer the question thus
historical angiographical scales thus
one can indeed pose questions at a
Himalayan scale
uh
that is to you can ask questions about
Himalayan resource use or about
Himalayan cultures or political forms or
linguistic change but the larger the
scale the more General and less specific
will be the answers
borders and Border studies make this
point very well because they
simultaneously address issues of context
scale practice and relation of local
cultures to the nation state
border people often straddle both sides
of of a political divide a line on the
map and for them the political order is
at the same time a hard and sometimes
violent fact an artificial line dividing
families and erasing old livelihoods at
the same time borders often make New
livelihoods possible and they can be a
force for cultural creativity since they
require the reorientation of old
patterns of interaction
but although boarders often illustrate
the fact that cultures are not
contiguous with nation states they also
show that the nation-state is by no
means irrelevant
and that it is often one of the most
powerful factors or actors in The
perpetuation and transformation of
cultures economies histories
environmental relations languages and
the like I want to conclude by offering
you two examples of this the first with
the
um oh yes I'm just going to show you all
the photos this is photos from the
research of my PhD student Christoph
Bergman who's just writing up now this
is during the kuncha the annual downward
migration in fact
towardsula
that's looking up towards Tibet
and we have a nice picture of the
Boatyard ladies at Festival time
this is a project that I've done with
geography funded by the German research
Council these darmias were formerly
responsible for the indo-tibetan trade
and the problem we posed ourselves was
what happened to their situation when
the Border was closed
so here already the geographical context
is fundamental because of the nature of
the trade and so is the political one
since they were bound up with the great
game as it happened to play out in the
20th century
the Border turns out to have been a
resource for the bohotias in many ways
in the colonial times they had they
maintained a kind of double identity
with a particular uh idea identity when
they're on the Tibetan side a different
idea of when they're on the Indian side
they managed to keep their Monopoly on
this trade by representing themselves to
Hindus as Yak eating Buddhists and maybe
they did something else representing
themselves to the Tibetans only on the
other side
um
they worked at various scales and each
of these scales had its own context with
their mitras or trade Partners in Tibet
with the colonial officials in India
with an india-wide trading Network you
see it goes up and up and up and finally
you get to the level of international
politics in the great game with the
so-called pundits beginning with nancing
and his uh mapping of Tibet for the
British
the Border was closed in 1962 and one
might think an essential part of their
identity was lost but it turns out that
this is not so traumatic as we had
supposed and this is because these
traits were not essential
um so you see these three parts which I
didn't elaborate for you the context of
the geographical context the context of
trade the context of colonial politics
effects the story that you tell about
them and the questions you ask the scale
uh trading networks of various size
involvement in the grade game National
and state Politics the scale also
affects the appropriate methodology to
use but it goes on there's a scale
jumping back to the Village scale now
when these people come up from Delhi or
from dehradun put on their tract
um we call that in English their native
dress to participate in the festival and
so on and so forth I had to skip a lot
of this project today to stay within the
time limit but in the longer version I
would try to show that continual change
and continual performance of local
cultures show that one part of the
transcultural critique of area studies
and of the culture idea is correct
culture is hybrid changing adaptive and
not essential but it also shows
convincingly to me that the notion of
botia culture can be defended and
grounded even if the description of that
culture varies according to scale and
context
the second example is the monograph that
I'm working on right now
which begins with the Shimla stage ever
notice these tiny tiny little post
postage stamp size states around Shimla
the so-called Shimla Hill States well
basically in my book I'm going to
try to say something about the
pre-colonial polity of these states
this polity was a polity of government
by deity where decisions were made by
national deities through their Oracles
in temples which were simultaneously
temples fortresses and palaces now this
all sounds a little bit outlandish
perhaps it does I know to some of my
colleagues it's interesting to note that
every single historian who's written
about this area without exception would
confirm this so this is the accepted
wisdom this idea of government by deity
through local oracles is really not
controversial and the fact that
um and the fact that the temple and the
residents and the uh Fortress are all in
the same building gives rise to the very
spectacular architecture of this place
this is one that was just rebuilt a
couple of years ago this is on the road
between now
and rampur
going over into the
um
sutledge Valley
and here are some more of these
fantastic local temples
um
so these tiny little kingdoms had
permanent relations of hostility and
warfare and this hostilian Warfare in uh
was associated with some very
interesting uh Customs particularly head
hunting
which uh Denny Vidal has written a
little bit about uh not much about this
but you'll have a lot of head hunting
stories and rituals in my book and
constant feuding very elaborate
traditions of Feud
so with my anthropological nose I found
the valley where the vestiges the
most vestiges of this old system still
persist and in this Valley or I would
say traditionally as well the landscape
uh here's a quotation from the first
chapter
the landscape is divided up among local
deities who jealously and often
violently protect their territories from
incursion by the others the constituent
groups of the local social structure the
castes are defined in terms of their
relationships to these deities for whom
they act as priests ministers patrons
soldiers and servants important local
decisions are made in the temple
compound by a Council of Elders and
ratified by the God's Oracle the deity
has the power to appoint and dismiss
officers confiscate property Levy fines
he hears civil and criminal cases
enforces his judgment diagnosis
Misfortune heals sickness welcomes
Brides bless his firstborn males settles
legal disputes meets out punishment
selects Temple officials formulates
Group Policy distributes grazing and
irrigation Rights defines territory etc
etc have a long list of all of the
things so
traditionally this government by deity
was a pretty well defined system where
the gods had particular Powers which
they exercised and I've tried to
represent this oops
where am I
um
to be there
I've tried to represent this in a kind
of abstract map where in the center of
each one of these tiny little
territories and you have to realize
they're very very small perhaps 20
kilometers across even less so at the
center of everyone is the deity in this
Temple surrounded by this sort of model
where the various castes are defined in
relationship to the king and the deity
is called a Raja this is not a metaphor
this is a kind of literal understanding
so that's the my abstract representation
of the polity now of course the the head
hunting is gone although it's not been
as gone as for as long as you might
think I thought it must have died out in
about the 19th century but Denny wrote a
very nice article about the last
recorded case of head hunting it was in
1932.
uh but the deities go around on their
palankines and they Patrol the border of
their territories uh still and this will
be the cover of the book this is the god
mahasu with his sword in the front you
know a very nice picture the image of
the Goddess inside the silver casket and
these fallenkins are carried around the
periphery of the territory
so there he is going along the
palantines are much much larger in kinar
here they're a bit smaller
and this is the oracle who accompanies
the deity and uh will adjudicate
decisions along the path
this is the Oracle of someshwara
otherwise known as duryodhana
um so he circles he circulates along
these borders to defend his territory
and there's still quite a bit of
violence because of this rivalry between
them they're always trying to cross the
border and get into the other one's
territory you do this nowadays by
getting an outmarried woman to invite
the god to do a ritual so he scuttles
across he does a ritual the local people
find out about it and there's a lot of
violence and a lot of drinking
um
so in the time that I have been working
in this area since the early 90s a new
scale has been imposed on local culture
it's only recently I would argue that
they've really been inducted
administratively linguistically
educationally into the mainstream of
Modern India
so that nowadays ambitious men
who need require allies right in the old
days to be ambitious was to develop a
following within one of these bounded
little territories but now if you want
to if you're ambitious you try to make
political connections across the old
units so you're reaching out those guys
whose heads you used to cut are now the
people who might be an ally with you
within the political party organization
and give you access to all of the
largesse which comes along with
political power
um
so the former head hunting Rivals are
now potential allies and of course the
infrastructure has reached these remote
Villages they still uh don't have
electricity or telephones but they do
have roads and so to my representation
of this is that map where the old
borders have now become rather porous in
the old system these units were
endogamous you only married within the
unit basically now we have exogamous
marriage between the various groups and
we have political and economic relations
across the old borders so in a sense
they're still ritually maintained the
patrols still go on but you don't kill
or behead your enemies anymore you just
rough them off a little bit and in fact
in my in the book A lot of the most
extensive ethnographic case studies will
be about how these issues are now
negotiated rather than uh violently
settled
so the book is all about these changes
and this kind of integration and it
supports the argument I tried to make
today which is that these three factors
of context practice and scale are
important for defining the level of the
region that you want to talk about the
context
pastoral
peripheral weak political relations with
neighbors strong political relations
practice that is crucial changes into
forms of dispute settlement changes in
marriage
patterns in political actions changes in
ritual and so forth these kinds of
changes in practice fashion new kinds of
subjectivities and the subjectivities
have to be
explained in terms of various scales and
in particular in this book we're talking
about a shift of scale from a local very
small Kingdom to an integration within
the Indian State finally it shows that
political borders are of great
importance certainly they are not
Eternal certainly they change over time
like these but so there are two
conclusions to my talk which is first
just to summarize the first part that by
no means should we Define area studies
in terms of political borders we do it
all the time but we do it unthinkingly
and we should think about it
and do it less but secondly that
political borders are indeed of great
importance and must play a large part in
area studies even if they should not
Define it thank you
like some of the earlier commentators
also I
um address these very very interesting
presentation from a perspective outside
of the Himalayas and I will make a few
observations from from this point of
view because I work in a region which
spans silhet in today's North Bangladesh
to the Burmese border which includes the
Northeast Bengal calcium and Manipur and
to a certain extent it also extends
Burma into Union however 200 years ago
since I work as a historian
so in that work no modern boundary
Supply and the formation of politics was
entirely different and greatly varied
it also means that the region I work in
just like William said here it's cut
into various academic institutional
sub-regions like South Asia southeast
Asia and East Asia
most significantly in spite of being a
historical study the work is seriously
affected by these specific political
situation in present-day Northeast India
so when I listen to the presentations
throughout this conference
um I feel that this is a kind of
experience I have in common with with
many of you who research in the
Himalayas
the geographical designation of
Northeast India and its Colonial
predecessor the British East India
companies North Eastern Frontier Lambs
together a great variety of politics
people's identities histories and so on
and hides these behind a geographical
label that indicates it is far away from
a center
so Ken's question slightly rephrased
when is the Northeast is very relevant
and Williams words of caution here also
apply that
studies of Northeast India is now
emerging as a separate field especially
within Borderland research and therefore
it risks rarifying the region that is
seen as a violation in the first place
like the Himalayas this large region was
itself a center of communication both
for the British as well as for the
Republic of India it's a gateway to
China within itself among other things
it was defined by Mobility so there are
obvious connections with Himalayas
um the session discussion discusses
States and borders and both phenomena
are as has been mentioned associated
with fixed and perhaps not permanent
characteristics but that's the general
Association
as so many presentations have shown
neither politics nor borders were fixed
they were negotiable they moved they
changed and perhaps at times we mistake
rhetorics for being political realities
that is to say that a polity needs to
refer to ancient posts and long
genealogies to prove its legitimacy in
times of uncertainty
Sarah has challenged us to analytically
contrast boundaries and closing polities
with an unbounded Himalaya so this is
the contrast between the heavily guarded
International borders and the borders
that are renegotiated in everyday life
as Saul reminded us James Scott
suggested that borders are questioned
trespassed and very difficult to
maintain I'd also say that borders are
poorests often made up of points of
specific significance like narrow
passages of rivers for custom points
Heights or other places that can be
defended against an enemy or a point
just beyond a Marketplace
demarcations between two politics may
not be manifested in a boundary line and
the polities do not need to be enclosed
by a border and yet the landscape can be
bounded or the other way around if we
think of a region as unbounded it can
still include borders which are
routinely trespassed
we may think of the Ivan gujas in
uttarakhand who migrate seasonally with
their buffalos between the lower hills
around heredoun and the high mountains
and doing so they cross the rajaji
national park the new agrarian lands and
state borders including different
restricting regulations
often describes the border between
kachin and Northeast Burma and Yunnan
which is heavily guarded border but
where but where a lot of people daily
climbed through the fence to go to the
market or to go for work and then they
return in the evening through the same
hole in the fence
another kind of order appeared when
Colonial rulers applied the principles
of subsidiary Alliance this is a very
nice word for a nasty thing it's a form
of suzerain or indirect rule that is
they fenced in a polity by not allowing
it to have foreign relations and thereby
a kingdom was cut off from its outer
relations it was a diplomatically
bounded landscape where linked to allies
or proclamations of War on an enemy were
effectively cut so Ken's expression that
borders were hardened is very useful
it's a process
um and then a final observation many
presentations have emphasized flows and
movements like migrations for whatever
reason commercial flows troops and
prisoners taken at War ideas and
knowledge and so on in my own work I
could add the movement of fire when
Villages were systematically burnt
people massacred and women raped either
by soldiers on the British flag or by
Naga and manipuri groups now such
movements or flows of violence caused
Domino effects in other regions into
which people fled
the more peaceful movements followed
Roots along rivers and across land and
it's been useful in my own work to
observe that roots of communication may
be equally or even more important than
focusing on territory
a most effective boundary would
therefore be to block the communication
that is to exercise Authority and to
have the capacity to control the flow
so when I've plotted such places on maps
of the British Northeastern Frontier it
looks like a Starry Sky and very far
from a borderline and yet this landscape
was very clearly bounded
and perhaps also in conjunction the
identity is probably yesterday is about
what the difference between talking
about Himalayan identity versus talking
about a border identity might be the
particular context we're talking about
because there was a start Ken that you
said you haven't seen the term Himalayan
used I did notice in Jeff's visuals one
of the schools you were talking about
does Bill itself as a school for
Himalayan children I have seen the term
used in several other comparable
circumstances sign boards or Association
names or whatever certainly in the
Nepali context also in Indian context in
barcelon and sakim I do think that it
has more circulation than some of us
have wanted to give it credit to but
give it credit for but what I'd like to
say also is that in much of my own
research which focuses on people moving
back and forth between Nepal those
Eastern areas of India and then um Tibet
people have conceptualized themselves
and the kind of language they use as
well as people who cross borders and as
people who For Whom the experience of
these multiple locations is an integral
part of identity that's something that
Chris uh vasant Kumar mentioned
yesterday as well the experience of
Elsewhere is somehow constituted about
being in a particular place but the
point is I mean they use kind of various
phrases to talk about that orderness or
that kind of Mobility but I've asked
myself quite often do they actually talk
about themselves as Himalayan people and
so and and in some cases they actually
will invoke that term and that's
something which has been there for a
long time it's not just a modern thing
in fact people will talk about it in
reference to the pre-1950 period where
many people from the central eastern
parts of Nepal where I've worked had
never been to Kathmandu but they had
been in Darjeeling Sikkim that in fact
into Tibet and so they did have used
this rubric as somehow people who move
across the mountains or people who are
Himalayan in nature to describe
themselves and in that particular
context I think that the the meaning of
Himalayan has transformed us it's been
picking up taken up in these more recent
political context but it does have a
kind of older substrate there perhaps
and I would be interested to hear what
all of you think about that you know how
we talk about Himalayan versus how we
talk about border peoples is there a
slippage between those different not
sure about border peoples of course the
analogous word that is used a lot is
bahati which in all the at least in
Nepal and in uh Western Himalaya refers
to the dominant group I don't know what
happens to that word when the farther
east you go that's the word that's used
and it happens then to refer to a group
which is I guess you'd have to say
politically a kind of in terms of power
or political economic dominance is the
core group
what happens to it in the east east
Nepal I don't know and then so Kim and
so forth does that word maintain that
kind of valence there
how about Bhutan
um
which is an aspect of the fact that it
refers to the dominant group as it does
the idea of Himalaya and you say
obviously it's mountains and mountain
people and then you say when to get this
idea arrived and then after the 60s and
I would say no that we are big we have
to be aware of that because now most of
the Himalayan people are living in the
plane and for example in Nepal the
majority of the population is in Nepal
more than 50 percent of the population
so I was speaking about and as this idea
of the Himalayas is not emerging now
that it's an Heritage so we are speaking
about people who are normal in the
mountains no more of course but most of
them are now into place so this idea of
post 1960s is said maybe 40 minutes
but everywhere elsewhere
so while the size of the himalayanas
mountains and the female and people has
to be just a little bit separated and uh
separated yes but you still have to
start today the St Patrick about all
those Irish in America who are wearing
green today by the way if you're not
wearing green you can are subject to
pinching in this country today at least
when I grew up because it's St Patrick's
Day and they're having parades so
they're still I mean that doesn't mean
that Ireland is irrelevant to their
being Irish it just means it's been
transformed somehow like those Himalayan
people dwelling in uh
in New Haven I mean it's still I I want
to defend my idea that you know this
this very practical thing ultimately
it's a mountain range and all of these
derivative meanings are really important
maybe they're the sorts of things we're
going to study about
okay I don't see any hands I mean we are
coming towards the end so well Sarah I
would like to I don't know if the other
people would no one really had a chance
to respond too much I said
this Bahari business but I wasn't really
a reaction to your question it's gonna
sit as well as that you know one doesn't
actually have to live in the high
doctors or even have a Heritage in the
high mountains are saying consider
consider itself
person right and I think I mean that's
certainly the case in the context
remember before we're talking about mid
Hills Nepal and you know what might be
the equivalent to kind of need Hills
Northeast India but the Topography is
not one where people are actually you
know the the high mountain or the kind
of uh at least stereotypical they would
say Himalayan communities such as uh
sure
et cetera where there is already this in
direct linkage but I think that I think
you talked about as a physicality of the
Himalayas that's the starting point but
it's certainly not the ending point as
as Chris and the many others also
mentioned it extends much further and I
think there is four people who have a
sense of a kind of Mobility or a
dislocation from a nation-state center
it actually is a rubric of
self-orientation as well even if the
one's position uh is quite far in
distance from the mountains themselves
it's an orienting it's a kind of site of
orientation yeah well who is the
question was who is the Border people
and what kinds of words and who thinks
of themselves that way and so forth yeah
you know I can only speak uh confidently
about about
Khan but they're all along the border
people those people up high they're not
baharis
the word that the baharis use and Bahari
is used for those mid-range people and
the people down in the today they're not
Bahari say the paharis are that vast
they're the 80 percent of the population
almost all Hindu who live in the middle
ranges uh and so from that's from their
perspective
it's those bodies who are the Border
people but then all those paharis who go
down to Delhi as domestic laborers are
marginalized and regarded as sort of uh
subaltern hillbillies with funny customs
and so at least in a metaphorical sense
then they become they become the people
from the margin
so again it depends on the question
you're asking I think we can all be
bordered we can all be border people in
our disciplines or uh borderline if we
haven't got enough sleep perhaps
yes please
um well I think you mentioned earlier
that one where it doesn't get mentioned
is Kashmir
but I think another word that doesn't
get mentioned which is the elephant in
the room which
did cue us with it is China
we don't seem to want to talk about
China
I I wonder if we're I'm apologizing our
discussion
I wonder if we're talking about not
really talking about area studies but
talking about ethnography
the sort of micro study I mean of course
historians I'm dramatizing
but we're our our interest in the micro
study which is fabulous and important
and nourishing and essential it can make
us Overlook these these big questions
that you mentioned and for example
you know the reason we're I would say
why we're interested in certain kinds of
Mobility
like the work Chris mentioned yesterday
and we all talked about with borders
crazy is is because of the emergence of
modern China in 1949 50 and the closing
of borders in India China Wars
and the history I think of China that
China at the moment is a history of
China very very decisively and there's
even some literature in Chinese about it
the descriptively not analytically I
think uh changing the flow of politics
and culture of the Himalayan area from
us the cutting off the South North Road
making it a East-West verb hugely
important to Chinese thinking about
history and politics and unimaginally
according to economics so interesting
that someone mentioned I think yesterday
I don't remember that but now when you
put in a trade route between China and
India it will be transitional it will
miss the local areas the truck drivers
who and the beneficiaries will beat
people at the other end of their room
not the local people that passes through
as we know it's going to happen probably
in the nepala China is you know we need
to bring in these big States although as
sep you know postmodern thinkers we want
to talk them away
China provides Aid to the Border
communities in Nepal and think about
that in terms of borders and how we
envision it so you're absolutely right
China should be pretty Central
conversation
yeah
I mean these are going to be their
critical issues yes and India China
relationship
is going to be the major driver in terms
of how these issues are resolved and how
we
try to create this
which we are visualizing there
and I think those are and I think I
really appreciated your comments early
on in terms of but AC Moore is doing and
what we do which all of us all of us in
this room have to make contributions
I had noticed Professor Lama is not here
today but I was talking with him
yesterday and he'd been on that
commission about opening up the natsula
pass and I was pressing him I was saying
well which one's going to open up next
and when is it going to happen and
what's the what's the timeline and he
said well the interesting idea is that
when the Chinese government brings its
railroad over to uh Google by 2019
that the Indians are thinking of selling
them electricity
because they've got the they've got a
lot of trade possibilities and we've got
a railroad but they don't have any power
generation so the one idea that um
apparently finds favor I may be
miscoding him I'm sorry but it's
relevant is uh to use all this power
generated in the body Himalayan Hydro
stations to sell it to the Chinese in
Western Tibet
okay I think we have to end and I'm
looking and you so let me thank the
panelists as well as the responded for
their excellent presentation
and for the audience also for remaining
till the end